al norte dejar kit de sal típica es una
zona desierta la artillería rusa
bombardeada esta zona residencial día y
noche
todos los habitantes han huido o casi
cotto
transmisión
solo algunos cuantos como luzmila han
decidido quedarse
siempre yo
el 23 de marzo un misil alcanzó su
edificio
otros nacimientos de la fiesta
expresiva
otros
y cigüeñas sobre ti
esta familia ha huido a un lugar más
seguro pero vienen al barrio todos los
días por solidaridad
y
aquí la lluvia de bombardeos de rusia
salpica la vida cotidiana en heart que
ya se ha cobrado la vida de al menos 300
civiles
cada vez que hay una alerta luz mila de
75 años se refugia en el sótano que
comparte con su vecino sanya
e
como esta leche
mal
luzmila era profesora de música lleva
cinco semanas encerrada en su refugio
por fin una tregua
el vecino aprovecha para llevarnos al
quinto piso
donde cayó el misil
sanya es de origen ruso
esta guerra entre hermanos los superados
werner sinn houston ingenio nieto
de búsquedas y simplón ya sabes que
ahora busca grandes games al usuario
seleccionar mal a whatsapp para los
idiomas
el solo punto
pero
esta vez los disparos vienen del lado
ucraniano
los enfrentamientos continúan cerca de
jarquín en los últimos días las fuerzas
ucranianas afirmaron haber lanzado una
contraofensiva y haber logrado recuperar
parte del territorio al este